[Rires]
pour conforter ce monde parallèle il y a
toute une gamme de produits ici une
couverture pour bloquer les ondes
électromagnétiques là une machine
impensable censée résoudre la pandémie
de regarder la tête de Thomas
qui vit l'actualité à fond on l'a vu
encore à l'instant merci à tous
oui définitivement
2500 dollars l'équivalent en euros
et quand Barack Obama revient dans le
débat public c'est rarement pour
annoncer de bonnes nouvelles
c'est la démocratie qui est en jeu dans
cette élection les républicains ne
cessent de répéter des mensonges en
disant que toutes les élections depuis
15 ans sont fausses j'ai été en campagne
électorale on dit parfois n'importe on
dit parfois n'importe quoi en campagne
électorale mais je constate mais oui
malheureusement électorale j'ai une
autre
idée de la politique je là alors là
franchement vous je la campagne
électorale qui vient de se passer ou me
la faites voir d'une manière différente
je commence à comprendre
c'est comme une partie de football entre
deux équipes et qu'une personne autre
que l'arbitre dise
et c'est cette équipe qui a gagné si
vous n'êtes pas prêt à faire ça pour un
match de foot alors pourquoi le
seriez-vous pour une élection pour ces
écureuils présents dans son jardin il a
vu les choses en grand et preuve
spectaculaire production soignée et
exploit commenter
[Musique]
13 millions de personnes ont regardé
cette vidéo de plus de 20 minutes pour
savoir qui a finalement remporté cette
coupe de noix bonjour Gabriel bonjour
Sonia Mabrouk sur le projet autour de
l'immigration vous allez donc être
gentil avec les gentils et méchants avec
les méchants c'est un élément de langage
qui a été commandé sur sur wish quand
quelqu'un vient demander l'asile en
France nous devons regarder son nazi
sérieusement si c'est non c'est non
Édouard partir si c'est oui on doit bien
le traiter simplement on doit le faire
plus vite donc une famille Zidi j'ai
compris qui arrive en France c'est là
quelques centaines d'euros pour vivre
dans un hôtel miteux en attendant
qu'administration française lui donne
une réponse je trouve que c'est pas
parfaitement scandaleux
[Musique]
c'est trop mignon à la rencontre des
ouvriers népalais qui construisaient les
hôtels et les stades de la Coupe du
monde à Doha
une vie de forçat
pour 300 euros par mois
3 fois plus que le salaire moyen dans
leur pays
travaillent à volonté
sous des températures caniculaires pour
un adulte isolé hébergé pour un
demandeur d'asile en Allemagne c'est 307
euros et en France et 207 donc
l'Allemagne c'est 150 euros de plus que
nous alors ça c'est pour un adulte isolé
hébergé en demande d'adultes et moi vous
avez dit
effectivement j'avais pas ces chiffres
là donc l'Allemagne est plus généreuse
que nous exactement donc la France est
moins généreuse que l'Allemagne j'ai
fait une bêtise j'en suis vraiment
désolé
[Musique]
un peu partout un peu trop tôt ça
entraîne un certain nombre de risques
regardez cette boule géante propulsée à
pleine allure ça c'est le vent les
intempéries à Londres qui ont fait que
cette boule s'est décrochée de son
emplacement est venu s'écraser dans
différents lampadaires au milieu du lac
desséché un bateau de pêcheurs abandonné
en Bolivie le lac Poupaud 3e plus grand
du pays au début des années c'est
complètement évaporé laissant le peuple
hourphelin
il ne reste rien ici beaucoup vivaient
ici avant mais ils sont partis
et ce rapport-là aussi est inquiétant il
est de l'Escaut il est sans appel à un
certain de glaciers des plus célèbres du
monde comme ceux des Dolomites en Italie
des parcs de Yosemite de Yellowstone aux
États-Unis ou encore du monde qui les
manjaro en Afrique disparaîtront d'ici
2050 sous l'effet du réchauffement
climatique entre 2003 et 2018 le glacier
oupsala en Argentine a reculé de 4 km
mais le changement est aussi visible sur
une période plus courte ici les
Dolomites en Italie en 2016 et en 2022
clairement si on n'avait pas trop prévu
on l'avait pas du tout vu selon l'Unesco
les glaciers concernés perdent en
moyenne 58 milliards de tonnes de glace
par an l'équivalent de la consommation
d'eau annuelle de la France et de
l'Espagne
et bien ici c'est pareil sauf que vous
allumez votre rue regardez on va faire
le petit test en direct c'est grâce à
cette application qui s'appelle j'allume
ma rue et là j'appuie et c'est censé
fonctionner et ça ne fonctionne pas je
ne sais pas pourquoi on va rejoindre le
on va rejoindre le créateur ah si ça y
est enfin et la lumière fut